- I have to ask this though 'cause I'm new
to the building.
I love working here.
- [Mikey] It's awesome.
- You, yeah.
- Welcome.
- Yes. So do you love it?
Do you have like your favorite places?
- I, it's fun seeing NBC,
like newscasters in the lobby.
I've seen Lester Holt
just walking in jeans,
which is.
- [Kelly] Which trips you out.
- You're like, you don't own jeans.
We're born in a suit.
So Rachel Maddow I've seen.
- [Kelly] Yeah,
- At the Starbucks.
- [Kelly] - Yeah.
- Down below.
- I know that Starbucks,
the Subway Starbucks, right?
- Yes. The Subway Starbucks.
- Have you ever been in
there like really early?
I had a early call time,
it was like six, 7:00 AM.
They were blasting music.
I was like,
- Oh really?
- Like, it was like a rave.
(panel laughs)
- And
- You like,
- I looked at these two and
I was like, it's 6 AM bro.
I was like, it's like that's early.
- Oh was it Kelly Clarkson music?
- [Kelly] No, not even great music.
- Then, I'm not going.
It's your music right now.
your music or nothing.
- [Kelly] It was actually good.
- Some people wait a lifetime.
They were moments like this
I watched that
- [Kelly] It would've
been more acceptable
at six AM.
- I watched that
and almost cried.
- I did cry.
- Well I was like, Kelly
deserves it so much.
Kelly's a star.
- Thank you.
- I was, I remember I was in college.
- I was, I was just telling
her the first season of Idol
our, they have a person every week too.
And ours was Burt Bacharach.
- [Mikey] Oh really?
- That came on that week, yeah.
And we did Burt Bacharach songs.
I did Walk on By before Doja.
- Before Doja.